So the California democratic state convention
happened over the weekend and there were some
interesting things that happen, including
including a lot of booing of presidential
candidates. I think you're going to like this.
First of all, there's a guy running named
John Delaney. He was a congressman in Maryland
from 2013 until this year. He's polling almost
zero, I think averaging, yeah, 0.5% to be
exact. So he has no shot, but he showed up
and he said Medicare for all might sound good
but it's not a good policy and it's not good
politics and he got booed so much that it
actually got awkward. Take a look.
But we need as Democrats to build an economy
that works, but it's gotta be with smart policies.
Medicare for all may sound good, but it's
actually not good policy nor is it good.
I'm telling you, I'm telling you a hundred
[inaudible] we should have universal healthcare.
We should have universal healthcare. Seriously
awkward moment because the booing just wouldn't
stop. But I'm going to take a position on
this that I know people are going to miss
here and get angry with me about. But if he
had tweaked what he said slightly, it would
have actually been a really strong statement
with which I'd agree because right now there
is huge momentum over medicare for all. But
as I've said before, medicare for all is just
one way to get universal coverage and healthcare
to everyone. I've said before, I'm a supporter
of Medicare for all over the system. We have,
and I'm a supporter of Medicare for all over
lots of other ideas that have been presented,
uh, including, you know, the public option
as part of Obamacare or whatever else. But
there are problems with Medicare. Medicare
is not nearly a perfect system. Would I take
it over what we have of course a million times
over.
But remember that 80% of the people who are
on Medicare have something else in addition
to Medicare because Medicare doesn't give
them full coverage. Some people are working
while on Medicare, so they have some kind
of private employer connected insurance. Some
people who have medicare are buying additional
coverage through various supplement plans
or they're poor enough to get Medicaid in
conjunction with Medicare. But the point is
medicare for all isn't perfect. And if Delaney
instead came in and said, listen, instead
of saying Medicare for all is bad politics
and bad policy, instead of saying my top priority
is getting healthcare to everyone as soon
as possible, and I will consider any system
that gets us there, be it medicare for all
a massive medicaid expansion, a nationalization
type system like in the UK, a state based
system that is similar to what Canada has
at the province level, it doesn't matter.
Right. That would actually be a really great
thing to hear from John Delaney because sometimes
I agree the left gets too, they get blinders
on with Medicare for all when there are other
options and it's a perfectly reasonable debate
to be had to show up and say, Hey, this is
bad policy and bad politics. He's a fool,
he's a fool. And if it's an idiotic way to
present it, uh, but there is actually a good
discussion in there that we could have, which
is Medicare is not perfect and there are other
countries that have different types of systems
which might be better if implemented in the
United States. And we should consider all
of them. We shouldn't rule any of it out.
I've been talking about that. So huge strategic
mistake by Delaney in a boneheaded way. A
really just putting his foot in his mouth.
Then in comes John Hickenlooper at the same
California Democratic convention, another
Democrat running with no support. He's pulling
0.3% Hickenlooper was the governor of Colorado
from 2013 until this year. And he said socialism
is not the answer and he got booed. Let's
take a look at that clip.
[inaudible] [inaudible] okay.
And the booing just went on from there. This
is another dumb strategic mistake. I agree
with Hickenlooper in that for me, socialism
is not the answer. I want, uh, to sort of
take control of the capitalist system that
we have and tweak and tailor it in the way
that the Nordic countries and other northern
European countries have done. Denmark, Finland,
whatever. These are capitalist countries that
have said, capitalism only goes so far and
we need to control it and rate it in for the
benefit of everybody in our country to make
sure people don't get left behind. So I agree
with Hickenlooper. Socialism is not the answer,
but socialism is a nonstarter, right? I mean,
who's running on the socialization of the
means of production were workers on every
business and there's no more private ownership
of business. I'm not for that. Nobody's running
on that.
Right? Why? Why is the guy even attacking
socialism at all? There's no candidates running
on socialist policies if it's an indirect
attack on Bernie. Okay. Bernie is running
on social democratic ideas like what we see
in countries like Denmark in those other countries.
When Trump yelled at his state of the Union
speech, we will never be a socialist country.
And the Republican's clapped and went crazy
and some republicans did too. I pointed out
this is idiotic red meat because there is
no serious risk that the United States is
going to become a socialist country. The Democratic
Party has almost no socialists in it. Uh,
it's a straw man. It's a complete and total
straw man. And similarly, when Hickenlooper
shows up and says, socialism is not the answer,
who's he talking to? Like, okay, there were
some people in the crowd who didn't like it.
I would bet that even most of those people
who think that they're socialists are actually
social democrats.
I know there are real socialists in the u
s a lot of them don't even understand that
they're actually social democrats. This is
yet another one of these dumb strategic mistakes.
Not that it matters for Hickenlooper because
the guy has absolutely no shot. Talk about
what you're for rather than socialism is not
the answer because who's talking about socialism?
I know that in some polls, socialism is less
unfavorably scene than it has been in a long
time. Again, many of those people are talking
about social democracy, but more importantly,
even if socialism is less unpopular than it
has been in a long time, which I agree it
is. I mean it's clear from the polls that
that that's the case. Socialism has been sort
of reinvigorated in some sense. We're not
fighting socialism. The Democratic primary
is not a socialism versus capitalism primary.
It's a how regulated of a capitalist system
are we arguing that we should have? How much
of the value created by capitalism do we believe
should be assigned to improving society? And
the economy for everyone, regardless of their
ability to pay on their economic circumstances.
He's having a debate with effectively nobody
when it comes to the content of the Democratic
Party, a party, dumb move, dumb move by Hickenlooper
and Delaney. But very little risks since neither
of them.
And have a shot my misinterpreting this. Let
me know what you think. Make sure to give
us a like on facebook@facebookdotcomslashdavidpakmanshow